it's nearly 30 degrees Celsius or 86
Fahrenheit and there's no shade but
that's perfect for these vegetables this
is a greenhouse in the middle of Berlin
where things like cucumbers and lettuce
a grow the companies to founders don't
come from a farming background but they
are businessman with the aim of selling
their vegetables right at the point of
harvest production in the city centre
allows us to make direct deliveries with
short transport routes no cold chains
it's very resource efficient it's a chef
from a neighboring restaurant stops by
today he's looking for fresh herbs and
cucumbers for the whole enterprise to be
profitable it has to be done on a
certain scale the urban farm yields 35
tons of vegetables each year from 1,800
square meters of surface area and
starting this 4 they will also be fresh
fish the pink perch are still growing in
basins behind the greenhouse Niklas
leshka hopes to sell 40,000 each year
and he plans to use the water from the
fish to raise the vegetables excretions
go through a biofilter and are turned
into nitrate the classic plant
fertilizer and that nitrate rich water
will be piped into the greenhouse and
used by the plants so the wastewater
from the fish becomes the fertilizer
water for the plants that way we can
make an organic fertilizer for the
plants Falk Marquita
thinks urban farming is the wave of the
future he's done research at the scar on
her fur Institute in Oberhausen with
among other things light here LED lights
replace the Sun indoors and use much
less energy than standard lamps
different colors and different
wavelengths result in different growth
rates in Swiss chard and Basel Coweta is
convinced that urban farming also has a
rosy economic future
he says the United States and Asia have
already made great strides there his
Institute develops LED systems for the
German subsidiary of a Japanese company
these systems are being developed not by
market gardens or startups like in
Germany or elsewhere in Europe but by
major tech companies the company like
Toshiba or Panasonic already has
experience with LED lighting so of
course they're approaching it from that
angle they already have the technology
they just have to adapt it for new
applications back in Berlin the two
company founders are also thinking big
they've been selling their urban farming
system to others and the entire concept
has won them several awards and just
recently they built a vegetable and fish
farm on the roof of a Swiss company but
in the future they want more of their
own farms in order to earn from them as
well our focus right now is on planning
and building farms like this for clients
we build them as general contractors
ready to use but I have an idea for the
future that's very important to me I'd
like to set up a supermarket chain in
the city and we can only do that with
our own firms Medina
the cucumbers are now ready to be served
in the restaurant nearby the head chef
is impressed by the quality of the
produce and several investors have also
developed a taste for the concept the
founders raised more than one and a half
million euros in capital last year to
expand their business now they just have
to prove that it will work